stupeur et erreurs sont apparus sur les
visages à vienne ce lundi soir à la
veille d'un reconfirme en national ce
sont 6 fusillade qui ont ensanglanté la
dernière soirée de liberté dans la
capitale autrichienne
les tirs ont eu lieu vers 20 heures à
plusieurs lieux stratégiques de la ville
notamment près d'une synagogue
plusieurs personnes sont mortes dont
l'un des assaillants quinze victimes ont
été hospitalisés dont sept dans un état
grave
malheureusement nous déplorons plusieurs
blessés plusieurs morts les unités
spéciales de la police ont réussi à
éliminer un terroriste armé d'un fusil
d'assaut automatique
et selon les informations dont nous
disposons actuellement au moins un
suspect est toujours en fuite
si pour l'heure il est impossible de
dire que la synagogue était visé le
gouvernement affirme que l'assaillant a
battu était sympathisant du groupe etat
islamique
hier soir le chancelier autrichien
sebastian course dénonçait déjà le
caractère terroriste de la taxe sur
twitter il a aussi annoncé le renfort
des forces armées pour retrouver un ou
plusieurs autres assaillants
notre république traverse actuellement
des moments difficiles je tiens à
remercier tous les services
d'intervention qui risquent leur vie
surtout aujourd'hui pour notre sécurité
notre police va prendre des initiatives
décisives contre les auteurs de cette
hideuse attaques terroristes afin que la
police puisse se concentrer pleinement
sur la lutte contre le terrorisme
le gouvernement fédéral a décidé que les
forces armées prendrait en charge la
protection des biens précédemment
assurée par la police à vienne avec
effet immédiat pour protéger la
communauté juive de vienne les
synagogues écoles juives et restaurants
casher resteront fermés ce mardi durant
les prochaines heures
les recherches vont s'intensifier pour
retrouver au moins un autre suspect